[Music]
okay thanks all for joining you're
welcome to my talk here at PI data about
async i/o I'll be explaining a bit the
jist of asynchronous programming in
general and show you how to do it in a
piping with package a sync right first a
small introduction my name is Niels
dancer I'm a data engineer and a bit of
a data scientist at the ing also banking
advanced analytics team I worked here
for one half years now before that
finished my master at the University of
interact and artificial intelligence and
I did a Bachelor in computer science
okay at the end of this session and you
will understand the fundamentals of
asynchronous programming so when we when
do you want to use it so when do you
think it will speed up your program how
you're able to you'll be able to write
your synchronous code into a synchronous
code and finally if we go really fast
you'll be able to know how to circumvent
some typical pitfalls as I used to a
sink io package welcome everybody
I figured out some some tips and tricks
and if we get to it I will explain them
as well
otherwise you'll find them on github
because all of these slides are there as
well ok so why did we makes a big
difference so why did we actually start
looking into async i/o we had a very
small well this is a simplified version
of it but we had a very small WebSocket
server which was receiving data from
multiple clients and we were writing
that to a database and to Kafka now
initially of course we started by
writing this in a synchronous way and
I've tried to visualize this in an
execution threat that you see on the
right here so let's say you first
receive your data this is a small orange
blob that maybe parses it or does
something to your data then starts
writing into a database now you'll see a
gap here which represents the wait time
that you need for writing something to
your database you have to send the data
over the wire and we'll take some time
before the database will tell you I'm
done writing now after the database is
done you'll start a center Kafka and
so you have to wait for this IO to
happen so there's again a small white
blob and then Kafka will be done you can
finish off your program now if you do if
you get a lot of messages in real time
you'll do this multiple times after each
other you can already see that there's a
couple of gaps in there that we might be
able to improve upon and that's exactly
what a synchronous code does so using
asynchronous code you're able to
actually leverage this this gap of wait
time mostly that's for i/o but it can be
any time of waiting in your program to
start messages start processing other
messages so when you get your first
message you have to wait for the
database to return but you can already
start processing the second message that
you've got and we'll see later on how
that actually happens now a third way of
doing this might be multi-threading but
that's a bit of a separate example
because technically you could also use
asynchronous code in multiple threads so
we'll see multi-threading to have a
small comparison between asynchronous
code but officially you can the best
example Barisan is between synchronous
and asynchronous code okay so why would
you want to do this well hopefully with
the pictures you saw in the previous
slide you're ready to get a bit of an
idea of why you would want to use this
you'll use your your threats more
efficiently you won't have to wait for
i/o to happen and to make it a bit a
little bit stronger you'll see here a
graph of times it took to load
marktplatz descriptions into a database
will see this example later on so I'll
dive into this a bit more when we get to
that but on the left hand side you'll
see the times this took in asynchronous
version of the code the synchronous
version of the code and to have a bit of
a comparison also to threats for threats
and eight threats roughly speaking the a
senior's version is three to four times
faster than the synchronous version
making it equally fast to four threats
roughly well we'll get to that later so
how does this actually work first a
small introduction into asynchronous
code in general so not necessarily at in
Python but in general how would you
write this and a normal a synchronous
program
has a loop this loop is actually used to
maintain all of the tasks that you
assign to this loop so you can assign
tasks to this loop and the loop will
tell a task you can start executing now
a task made at a certain point they'll
okay I have to wait for i/o so wait you
can you can execute something else so
would you typically start with you
initialize the loop I tell the loop you
will start working on task a somewhere
in the future still preparation can give
it another task you could give it as
many tasks as you like so let's do the
example with 2003 after you did this
initialization of the loop you can start
running it and the loop will check again
first toss that I got was tasks a so
let's give the control of execution to
task a task I can start executing a task
a starts doing its work in our example
that could be for instance receiving a
message from the WebSocket server and
doing some parsing on it at a certain
point the sky will say I am now gonna
write this to the database and I have to
wait for a little while so it initiates
the right call to the database and then
tells async I'll think you're on a later
stage but it tells the loop to I'm done
with the processing that I want to do
now I have to wait for the database to
get back to me so if you want you can do
anything else in between the loop will
get back this weight statement that
we'll see in the Python version later on
and the loop will say okay now then the
next task can start executing so it
gives the execution control mm that's me
in this example we'll do exactly the
same thing it will receive a new message
and whenever it goes to a database call
or any form of i/o it will give back to
control to the loop again in this
process just goes on infinitely or as
long as you specify the loop it's around
you can tell the loop to finish whenever
you would like to now if a in this
example for instance get the gets its
data back half way through those beats
executing then task a of course has to
wait a little longer which would make
good make it more inefficient but in the
end you're using your execution thread
more efficiently this way okay
key things to remember from this first
part you have to make sure all of your
tasks are programmed asynchronously
shortly get back to this say the task a
wouldn't be programmed asynchronously
this await keyword would never be used
by task a so basically the loop would
tell task a to start executing and if
task a is a synchronous program task
able just to hog all the resources and
keep on executing will never tell the
loop to get back to do something doing
something else so you don't want to have
synchronous tasks in your asynchronous
program first important thing is all
your tasks have to be asynchronous that
you want to use in your asynchronous
program secondly we saw that already if
you create an event loop the event loop
will control stuff for you will maintain
the execution threat for all your tasks
yes to the assignee starts to the event
loop and finally you have to run the
event loop and tell it when to stop okay
enough of the theory let's look at some
code so we'll start with a simple
synchronous example of a PI data talk
you'll see that it will start with
printing welcome and then has some sleep
buried in there that's to simulate any
kind of i/o operation or weight
operation that you'd have to do in the
code question mark sleep prophet and
hopefully it will return knowledge yeah
so we can see that actually does it now
how do we write this asynchronously this
small example program for that we need
two things in Python you have two
keywords that support this ever since
3.5 it's the async in the array keyword
before that maybe some of you looked at
it as well you had the async i/o dot go
routine keyword and yield from and now
we have a sink and a weight a thing
tells python that this function will be
an asynchronous function and a weight
will tell the interpreter at this point
in time I can give that control to do so
we saw that in the visualization already
now let's rewrite this by data talk
function to it's asynchronous version
okay well first of all for that we need
a sink IO
should make sense as we saw before we
have to tell Python that this will be an
asynchronous program asynchronous
function so we put a sink there and at
every point in time where we want to
give back control to the loop all of
these sleep statements we're not doing
anything we're just waiting you want to
give that control to the loop and we
tell it by putting your weight there
yeah if I run this and we look at the
next point in time what do you think
will happen when we call this function
[Music]
anybody an ID let's just call it yes so
maybe you thought if we print
welcome question mark profit and return
knowledge but it doesn't do that it
actually gives you a curtain object
that's because we put the async keyword
there
which doesn't make it if it's
technically still as a function but it's
not a function you can call directly
anymore it's just a function that you
give to a loop object so the loop can
actually run this object so remember we
had two or three tasks left to do we
rewrote this program to is asynchronous
version but we still have to create loop
object let's do that here so I think we
can get the event loop this way this
will create a loop object and I think I
will have to assign the task student to
the loop you can do that using create
tasks and let's say we run this by data
talk function here with a sleep of what
second and this create task object will
if you actually give you back a task
object that you can later use to check
if this task is completed so we'll catch
the object that gets back task a and
then we finally have to run the loop
okay how do we do this well we can use
multiple versions we'll see
run forever later on as well but one of
the ways to do this is to use run until
complete we can say run this until task
a completes so I'll run as long as this
task finishes so let's see what is this
it starts printing welcome and then
immediately gives us a type
now why is that so let's see what it
says it says object non type can be used
in an away discretion the function we
use on top here time not sleep
it doesn't actually give you back an
available object so this time that sleep
function isn't capable of executing
asynchronously so that's what's step one
in our program we have to make sure
everything runs asynchronously
everything has to be capable of giving
this control back to the loop so
unfortunately we cannot use time to
sleep but fortunately I think IO has a
sleep function as well that is able to
do this so let's see what happens if we
run this again luckily we'll get a
regular program back welcome question
mark profit over technology now this is
not so interesting yet maybe because we
have one task so this task will give
that control to the loop the loop will
just wait as long until this task can
execute again because there's nothing
else to do so you cannot actually
leverage the wait time yet for that we
need a second task so let's create a
second asynchronous task let's say it
would like to drink water during giving
my PI data talk and this function will
just print first sip second sip and in
between we will again do a nice I think
I'll sleep just wait a bit if I drink
too much I might have to go to the
bathroom so let's see what happens if we
run this as you can see I create two
task objects again catch them in a in
the function and I will run until
complete this task drink function what
you'll see now is that this loop object
actually started giving control to the
task that was ready to execute something
so first it starts with printing welcome
which was the PI data talk function that
we saw the PI data talk function will at
that point in time say okay I'm done
executing I have an await stable now the
loop can start something else and the
loop gave the execution threat to the
Drinkwater function at first it will be
printed but you may have noticed is that
we haven't
yep gotten any profit out of this talk
and we didn't get knowledge back yet so
how do you actually do this and why is
that that is because we have this run
until complete only until the string
completes so the loop will say whenever
I get a return statement from task drink
our return this is what you see bathroom
break being returned and I'll stop and
we can actually see that if we run the
loop again until task star completes
that there's our leftover parts of the
program so you have to make sure that
you run this loop until all the tasks
are finished and you can do this in a in
a more proper way by using async I out
gather this will actually gather the two
future to do tasks into a single task
that you can await and make sure that
both of these are finished so if we run
this will see that it again interleaves
operations of the two tasks and finally
returns lists of both return statements
knowledge and Bufferin break because we
gave it in that order so it's a way of
properly executing multiple tasks using
a single you see a small example if we
have time of doing this in a yet another
way okay so now we do we saw some code
and let's refer back to what we've what
we've seen key things to remember from
this again programmer tasks
asynchronously with the time that's
sleep we saw it doesn't work if you have
a synchronous version of a program in
there use the I think wait keywords for
that secondly create an event loop I
think I'll get event loop third give
these tasks to the event loop tell it to
start executing this in the future and
actually run the loop and make sure you
run until complete all of the tasks that
you want to complete
so what I understood from it is a sink
IO started with this syntax of using a
sink and a weight but it actually got
adopted by Python later on so the async
and weight keywords are not strictly
bound to a single anymore it's a
separate well way of writing functions
in Python so you don't have to use a
sink i/o at all you can even write your
own loop your own event loop I think
curieux is another version of an
asynchronous loop that also uses async
and await keywords but they think I open
for instance in this case provides you
with a sleep object and this loop object
that's the official adopted way by
Python now but there's multiple ways you
can write your own if you want to want
to see another version of it on get up
at the end of this presentation I don't
think I'll get to that there's a small
example of writing your own loop if
you'd like to so we saw a nice toy
example now hopefully got you a little
bit of how this async real library works
but this is not a very realistic example
so let's see what realistic example we
can actually do with async i/o what
we're gonna do is we're gonna scrape
pages from Molly Platts mark class is
the dutch version of ebay basically you
can buy second-hand stuff from people
there show you how it looks for instance
in our example here we're gonna look for
motorcycle stuff anything gets posted on
motorcycles and what our program
hopefully will do it will go to any page
of a motorcycle and then read its
description because we'd like to know
what worse words are used most by people
who tried to sell their motorcycle so
that's the use case of this this example
to fast I'll go through this a bit
globally I really don't want to dive
into every bit of code precisely but
hopefully you'll get the gist of it
we'll use the request library here and
beautifulsoup to parse HTML pages I have
small function here to get the soup from
good of beautiful soup out of a
requested HTML page what you'll see here
is we actually read in this article page
so it's one big page and then start
reading the subsequent post the article
posts in mark class and get the
description out of it we're going to
write that to a database later on so
this is a small generator that will
every time you call it generate one new
description from our plants you can see
that happening my Wi-Fi is connected
yeah well this is a very persuasive app
with all caps locks but if we go to this
generator just get a lot of this these
descriptions from our class now that's
the synchronous version of your
generator and you can use this to write
a synchronous version of your program so
what this program will do is it will
initiate the generator run through it so
in write everything here for instance it
will run through all of the pages in my
class that you want to run through and
finally do a psych up G right
so in this write function here we will
just simply insert this description into
our database that's all so we're reading
from our plats and right into our
database
that's the synchronous version we can
also do this in a multi-threaded way
multi-threaded is really easy we just
start with the number of threats that
you specify and we run a synchronous
version of the program and each of the
threats so that's multi-threaded in a
synchronous way and finally of course we
have an asynchronous way I'll dive into
this a little bit more we saw that we
had a synchronous generated before with
the request library now if you want to
write a asynchronous version of this
remember that you have to write your
program asynchronously so every part of
your program has to be asynchronous
now requests doesn't have the capability
of using you eight keywords so we need
another library in this case a i/o HTTP
which is able to use the AOL keyword and
actually can give that control to the
loop this is an i/o operation so we need
separate library for that so we use that
to rewrite the generator in an
asynchronous way note that here again I
use the async you were to specify this
is an asynchronous function and the you
eight statements whenever necessary
if I do add a call to this HTTP headers
now the asynchronous class itself is
actually doing calls to the database and
again we're writing to a database we use
the cycle g2 before in a synchronous
version again we need another library
that is able capable of giving back
control to the loop in this case I use
async PG you have a couple for Postgres
rights and for other databases and
you'll see here there's a small
alteration when I write everything I
have to create a task for every page I
would like to write so I'm using list
comprehension I create a number of tasks
for every separate page and I write the
super database run until complete again
they think I all together until all
these tasks complete now let's see what
this gives us small speed comparison and
actually that's the graph that you saw
in the beginning the asynchronous
version of this program roughly four
times as fast it can leverage of the
wait times you need for calling
marktplatz pages so a i/o HTTP gives you
this benefit and with async PG you can
actually speed up your database writes
in this case for instance if we're
writing a hundred pages to mark class
you can do this a number of different
ways you could spin up five tasks and
give them each twenty pages what I did
now is make a task for every separate
page that we write so one page contains
multiple articles so from writing a
hundred pages to from our class in my
database I start a hundred asynchronous
tasks that each will start with doing a
request to mark Plath's the first one
will say ok I'm now waiting for mark
class second one will start executing
and so on now if you want to look at a
bit more in depth this is just a
different visualization of the same same
data but now over time so on the x-axis
you'll see the Articles that have
written so the more articles who are
gonna write this scales linearly the
time it took to write these articles now
we had a problem so we also like to see
the solution of that of course the
engineering part of this is way more
interesting but result of this is our
homes it apparently is the most used
word to try to sell your motorcycle
motor is kind of obvious
Bart's a couple of words that are
interesting I have quite some time left
so I'll also walk through some learnings
that I've saw seen in practice first of
all there's exception handling so we saw
writing an asynchronous program you need
a loop object but handling exceptions is
very uncommon you'll see that now
passing data between tasks you may want
to do that and control your tasks so
there's a couple of timeout features
that you can use there I'll see how far
I get exception handling so say that we
have a small asynchronous function
please accept me then we'll first print
wait for it then it will wait for a
little while so that can actually see
that it's doing something and right
after it prints incoming we expect an
exception to happen now let's see what
is this if we run it we see wait for it
incoming exception that's exactly how we
would expect it to happen now why does
it work here that's because when you run
until complete the result of your
asynchronous function so in this case
the result of my please accept function
will be evaluated by relative complete
to return it in this function so you'll
see that the return statement
normally we saw that by data talk
function for instance return knowledge
so we actually got our return statement
right after we ran until complete here
we also evaluate the result which is an
exception so this stick case is still
fine but what if we look at different
case
if we want to run something indefinitely
so we saw in the beginning a WebSocket
server for example this WebSocket server
of course runs indefinitely so you'll be
waiting for messages coming in all the
time writing through the database as you
get them arriving to cough class you get
them as well
so I added a small while true loop here
that will just infinitely run this talk
belief is recorded so you can actually
do that if you want
we need a stopper because if we run a
task I think infinitely we'll never be
able to get back control so I added a
small stop function that is just waits
for the specified amount of time and
that stops the loop so you give the loop
object to it and using stop you can make
it stop now let's see what we what
happens when we run it here so you'll
see I'll create three tasks one task is
the PI data task the task that we just
saw it's an infinite running talk second
one is our except me which will give an
exception after two seconds hopefully
and the fourth task is our the third
task is our stopper which will wait four
seconds and then stop the loop now
normally you will expect an exception
after two seconds but let's see what
happens
yeah so we saw that immediately after
incoming in a previous version of the
program we got an exception and the
program failed as you would expect it to
fail but now we didn't get the exception
how come well we saw in the previous one
that we were using run until complete
the result of this task is being
evaluated
immediately after the run until complete
to see what's in what's in there and at
that point in time the exception is
thrown because the loop realizes that
there is an exception there in this case
we're running forever and the loop will
never evaluate the result of tasks
except even though the task except task
is completed so you'll not get the
exception and the beginning this is very
annoying when you're using async i/o you
have no idea what's going on
you expect an exception
it's not there so how can you circumvent
this I actually to show you that this
exception is there so when you get the
result of this task except task right
after this you'll see the exception is
still in there now to circumvent this
you can specify an exception handler and
give that to the loop object and the
loop object will use this exception
handler to execute whenever it finds an
exception in any of the tasks so what we
do here is we specify an exception
Handler and give it a loop object loop
object is the async i/o loop itself and
the contacts the contacts will be filled
by what the context of the exception is
we will stop the loop object because
normally that's what you would like to
happen when an exception occurs to stop
the program and print the exception and
we set the exception handler here so if
we create this task I didn't reset the
loop so the infinite by data talk
function is still in there
you'll see that that one starts printing
along with the wait for it incoming
function but now actually the exception
is not thrown in a nice way yet but it
at least is caught the loop is stopped
and you can print the exception and
handle panel accordingly now one thing I
figured out which can also cause some
headaches it's not really solution to it
yet but you may have noticed that in the
previous in this example here I didn't
actually catch the task object so I
started Luke create task but I didn't
assign it to a new variable of course
when you run the when you loop that run
forever you'll this will loop this will
run forever so you won't need to catch
this task object but say that you do it
anyway that's the very thing here go
back one that's the version you see here
we actually get the task object and we
try to do the exact same thing so this
loop object still has the exception
handler let's see what happens if we run
this one forever now no it's
action is thrown anymore very weird
because we just specified the exception
handler I also don't know if the answer
to it but I like to note this at least
there's a you would expect the exception
handler to catch this there's some guys
who are talking about this I think it's
still a bug basically what happened was
they think happens is the task is never
garbage collected and might do some
tricky stuff live through that but at
least note that if you actually catch
the task of Jack we're running it into a
complete running it forever
this might mess up your exceptions
anyway small extra stir extra tasks if
you want to pass data between tasks so
normally what you can do is you can
write tasks for every complete program
so if you want to receive messages from
a WebSocket server sent them to the
database and sent them to Kafka you can
do this in one program using your wait
statements but you could also do is
split up the program in receiving from
WebSockets putting that in a queue
that's what a queue is very useful for
and you have an asynchronous version of
queue then let the database handler pick
up from that queue and send to the
database and let the Kafka handler pick
up and sent to Khafre and we found that
that's a very nice way of passing
objects in between tasks so here I'll
have a small error which will loop over
a range of zero until five range shakes
put them in the queue and sleep for a
hundred of a second
and the reader which will take from this
queue now you see that this few object
I'll create in a later stage is again an
async i/o function it supports you eight
keywords which make sure that the
control is given back to the loop
immediately after you put it in the in
the queue so if we run this you'll see
here that we start a new version of the
loop I'm running all of this in one bite
the notebook so it can get a bit messy
with loops so I create a new loop object
and I set async i/o to use this new loop
object I create a asynchronous queue and
we
create two readers and one adder alum
will start adding tasks to the loop and
the readers will process them as
necessary finally we'll close the loop
now as you can see reader number one
reads the first message number zero
tweeter number two will pick up on the
on the second one number one and so on
and in this case you can actually see
that the loop gives back control of
gifts control to one function in a in a
ordered way
first the adder will be given control
who add something to the queue first
really will be given control then
nothing else can happen so the adder
will get back control we'll add it to
the loop the loop now things okay let's
give control to the second reader and
we'll do it in a fair way sorry I see
this reads one two three four five
looking at time I think it can shortly
explain you how to control tasks we saw
that I think I owe that Geller way of
controlling tasks which you can with
which you can combine two tasks into one
task and await them there's a second way
of doing it and that's using async I add
weight and it gives you a little bit
more functionality to for instance
specify a time out when one of the tasks
times out you would want to stop
executing if we use this one note here
that the time out I give it is one
second and tasks will actually sleep for
two seconds you'll see that if I run
this I think it will give me back there
still a task running in your loop but
see what you do with it if I try to get
the result of that task whoa result is
not ready yet now there's a couple more
small features in in there in the weight
you can also wait until the first task
completes not execute this now given
time and there's another one which will
stop until an exception occurs
all right I hope you've gained some
knowledge on how to do asynchronous
programming in Python using async i/o if
you'd like to see more of it there's a
bit more extra references after this
talk for instance how does async i/o
work on a hood not in very much detail
but a bit more than that I've given now
you can find it on get up on my page
thanks for listening
[Applause]